les livres de l'été aujourd'hui donc
deuxième invité de thierry françoise
sagan avec son dernier livre mon
meilleur souvenir aux éditions gallimard
alors ce livre n'est pas franchement un
livre de mémoires
mais françoise sagan y évoque toutes ses
passions et ses rencontres alors
françoise sagan justement ce titre avec
mon meilleur souvenir ça n'aurait est-ce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu le remplacer par
les premières mémoires de françoise
sagan et non parce qu'il y paraît je ne
pense pas à écrire mes mémoires d'un
jour jamais non et deuxièmement parmi
ces gens les gens les choses dont je
parle des mercis quelques personnes qui
sont vivantes encore et les choses dont
je vais parler qui nous ont plus
continuer à me plaire mais alors il ya
différents chapitres dans ce livre vous
évoquez votre passion pour le jeu pour
la vitesse en voiture pour saint-tropez
aise pour différentes rencontres que
vous avez fait jean paul sartre des
chanteurs comme des chanteuses comme
billie holiday des acteurs des metteurs
en scène comme orson welles alors
pourquoi avez vous eu envie jaillir d'un
seul coup de parler de deux de ses de
ces tranches de votre vie qui ont fait
beaucoup parler par exemple votre amour
du jeu sous le monde en a parlé votre
amour de la vitesse tout le monde en a
parlé
j'ai voulu et je voulais parler des de
toutes ces choses que je trouvais
suffisante et que j'admirais faire
l'espèce du récapitulatif optimiste de
des choses de la vie d'un des choses de
ma vie une plainte et il se trouve que
le jeu le asile sauf le hasard les
voitures en font partie mais c'est pas
son psy sont des choses qu'on me combe
reproche d'un type c'est un homme qui
peut nier quand même pas reprocher aux
gens nés mais le hasard ni il hérite s
cela dit vous ne vous étiez jamais
expliquée par exemple votre amour de la
vitesse vous expliquer très bien la
sensation que vous procure une voiture
qui roule très très vite alors est ce
que vous avez envie de vous justifiez de
2 de toutes ces différentes actions de
votre vue non plus
j'ai pensé à me justifier on se justifie
jamais dû merci mais le ska livre
amusant parce que les gens qui
m'écrivent qui m'en parlent
selon leurs goûts leurs goûts personnels
me parle ou de la vitesse mais allons y
pour la vitesse les autres pétitions
joueurs eux-mêmes les autres parce que
chacun a trouvé dans ses gains
alléchants qui lui autorise une petite
tronche qui leur plaisait
personnellement alors françoise sagan à
travers ce livre on revit certains
passages de votre vie qui ont défrayé la
chronique
mais par contre vous vous présentez
toujours commune j'allais dire non pas
une femme ordinaire mais qui n'a pas eu
d' aventure extraordinaire qu'a l'or
alors que par exemple votre amour du jeu
ce ne sont pas des choses ordinaires
pour le pour le public moyen obtient non
c'est un signe pour les gens qui jouent
le jeu qu'on compte quel que soit le
domaine que ce soit la fraction qu'on
joue aussi les gens qui jouent au pmu
tous les pluies dimanche sous des
émotions aussi violente que quand ils
voient la course la télévision les
émotions si violente que moi un casino
quelconque c'est le jeu c'est une chose
extrêmement extrêmement forte et c'est
peut être un fonds qui fera bout c'est
peut-être revenir à la ligne c'est
pareil dans ce livre france 5 ans on a
le sentiment que vous avez vous êtes à
différents moments de votre vie
engagé dans différentes vies possibles
et que vous y avez n'ont pas renoncé
mais que vous avez changé vous avez
dérivés à plusieurs moments si vous
aviez à revivre une dvi qui font les
chapitres est ce que vous choisiriez par
exemple aujourd'hui d'être simplement
une joueuse d'être une amateurs de
vitesse
est-ce que quel est le j'allais dire le
chapitre que vous aimez le plus ou l'art
est difficile
c'est difficile je vous dis entre ces
patients dont c'est que nous on ne peut
pas imaginer qu'on soit uniquement
centré sur une chose ou serait entré
monolithique où se construisent vous
dites qu est-ce qu il ne manquerait plus
qu à ski ou qu'est ce qui vous manque le
plus des choses que vous avez fait est
abandonnée aujourd'hui ou celle que vous
avez apprécié le plus on a traité je
n'ai pas tellement ce n'est pas
tellement abandonnez vous
oui les choses les dirigeants qui m'ont
abandonné parce qu'ils sont morts c'est
beaucoup plus triste mais là je crois
qu'une chose qu'il a choisi d'ancrer le
plus haut bien toyer si les livres quand
même si le fait d'écrire
oui aujourd'hui et vous en parler de
cette passion des faits vous parler par
exemple 100 sans vergogne vous parlez de
vos adaptation théâtre par exemple vous
parler du théâtre et vous parlez alors
contrairement à beaucoup d'écrivains
vous parlez là en toute franchise de vos
échecs au théâtre enfin après son côté
amusant que les succès parce que les
cantonales un succès au théâtre on doit
féliciter alors on la prend guère
modeste et dire non c'est pas moi ce
metteur en scène c'est par ses acteurs
ses passagers grâce à la fin on prend le
désert de pieux et confie que des
cocktails à l'échec d'une pâle pas mal
de gens qui sont assez contents vous
ayez un échec qui va nous serrer la main
car de dire alors là au contraire il
faut prendre l'air on est obligé de
prendre l'air même des vues des acteurs
qui sont souvent en larmes qui coulent
lobos est programmée fin tragique
c'est simon cocu driver haute contre les
chefs du passé il dit succès de revenus
ne tombiez de parader et le fait de
parader fini par me rendre l'âme part à
deux merci françoise sagan je rappelle
le titre de ce livre qui vient de sortir
aux éditions gallimard avec mon meilleur
souvenir